[Music]
normally there's this awkwardness around
disability but what that costume on
there that changed how people saw my son
they saw him first before they saw his
disability
it just helps break down that barrier
magic wheelchair is a nonprofit that
builds epic costumes for amazing kiddos
and wheelchairs magic wheelchairs
started when my son was 3 years old
Halloween rolled around and he wanted to
be a pirate we're new to the whole
disabilities and wheelchair thing we
didn't know anything about spinal
muscular atrophy I saw him sitting in
his wheelchair how we could dress them
up as a pirate be a pirate and
wheelchair and let's let's build a ship
we have made probably about 48 different
costumes we have teams right now all
over the country we have a team in
France and working on a team in
Australia we're just gonna keep on
boarding teams because we want to build
year round it's harder to build for
people that are in wheelchairs but it
ultimately starts with the kid it's
whatever they want to be and then we
make it a reality
[Music]
Halloween was kind of our initial push
but we're seeing like comic-con right
[Music]
and what's cool about that community of
cosplay that's a very supportive
community the the cold reality of
childhood diseases are some of them
won't be around for next Halloween
so let's find something that we can do
while they're here with us so they have
these that they have these great
memories and that their their families
have memories when they're gone
[Music]
it's almost like a cure for the day
because they don't see the wheelchair
they just see these amazing kids and it
bridges gaps and overcomes that
awkwardness that we have in society I
mean their star the show oh it's awesome
to see
[Music]
[Music]